foreign
let's go out to Sean in Richmond
Virginia what's up Sean
hey Dr John how are you partying man
what are you up to
oh man
um just fanboying right now
um I am fanboying too I'm Fanboy too
what's up man I'm uh uh so I'm been
using your your cards for humans uh to
better build my relationship with my
kids how does that work now or my six
year old oh it's great my six-year-old
is coming to me now asking what's the
best part of my day and what's the most
challenging part of my day wow that's
incredible man good for you
yeah so my question is how do I uh best
integrate my kids into another family of
kids
um I live in one of these awesome states
that make you stay separated for 12
months before finalizing divorce God
knows how long how much longer later
after that
um but uh did you did your attorney tell
you why they do that
no I need to ask now I have a buddy of
mine who's a legal scholar I I can't
think of a dumber law that's not true
there's we've got plenty of dumb laws
and I'm in Tennessee so we're we're
trying to just like hold my beer I can
make an even dumber one but like I I
just don't understand that at all I just
don't understand it but okay so 12
months okay so yes is your divorce not
finalized yet
not yet
um are you already dating
but I do have someone that I am very you
know curious to see what's going to
happen once the divorce is final yeah
it's kind of kind of like a middle
school like we're not going out we just
like make out that's cool Facebook
officials exactly oh geez okay so
um tell me what happened with your with
your marriage
um it was one of those where uh honestly
it was a lack of communication on both
ends um I was growing one way and she
was growing another way and our picture
of our future changed individually and
we never really sat down to repaint that
picture
um so it just kind of fell apart from
there and I tried to
do what I could to help better myself to
be a better husband better father and
you know she just wasn't uh wasn't into
it so
um I want to do marriage counseling and
uh she did not and that kind of told me
everything I needed to know there
who ultimately filed on who
uh we both sat down and
said you know we just need to
end it and both agreed okay um
so were how many months ago was was the
final
you all sat in a room and said this is
let's just be let's be done
uh about
10 months ago okay and then how long
before that how many years has it been
pretty chaotic and frustrating
um
probably two to three years beforehand
okay and then how old are your kids
uh 11 and 6. okay
and so the person that you're not you're
not Facebook official yet you're just
like
um uh tell me about them
uh she has three kids
um
ages 5 12 and 15.
um she's a freaking superhero in my book
she's raised those kids by herself
um she's an ER nurse
um so she lives in chaos and she still
finds ways to smile and laugh every
single day
Okay so
tell me your question
um what like best practices for
uh introducing and kind of integrating
the kids together okay
um so there's a couple of big rocks here
and then all I'll I'll let you speak
into some of it
um one of the big rocks is
just a hole in your back pocket is don't
ever introduce somebody to your kids
that you don't see a long-term connected
future with
right
um there's this there's kind of an uh
there's an idea floating around out
there that I hear a lot which is I need
to I need to show my kids that I'm
moving on past this hurt and that I'm
out dating again I want to I want to
provide a good picture of what dating
looks like
kids are desperate for one word in this
season stability
stability stability stability so before
you bring somebody else in
establish some routines on this is how
life is gonna go
and let there be some smoke clearing on
let those kids know this is their new
life
and then
six months down the road a year down the
road when you're convinced that This
Woman's a rock star and she's going to
be your next whatever and you thought
communication was hard last time but now
let's marry somebody's video ER drama
nurse with three kids
um one of which you will be driving by
then let's do that so we're going to
have established great communication
and then you're gonna Circle back and
slow so that's number one is
give some let there be some space make
this make sure this person is like no no
I see a legitimate future here the
second thing is this stability as I
talked about
um
and by the way that doesn't mean
normalcy there is no normal like the kid
for the kids it's oh just can't it's
chaos so we're gonna provide some
stability we're gonna have some routines
we're gonna have some this is the way
this is
um and I think it's important for you
you've been ready for this for years
right
and right now this woman that you're
talking to may have been talking to how
long have you been talking to her for
two years three years ten months we've
known each other for about 10 years okay
um so she's not like a she's not a
stranger she's someone that um I do
trust very much and I know very well
um when did you have feelings for
oh
and be honest probably about
three months ago okay that was the first
time you've been like ah Maybe
yeah yeah after 10 years come on Sean
I mean we uh we've always been like good
friends had a really good connection
from the beginning
um
and yeah it's just kind of one of those
things where it's like yeah this is what
I what I've been missing okay I I can't
emphasize this enough that as good as it
feels to finally have what feels like in
your life
um like a partner someone on the same
team someone who laughs at the same
things you laugh at whatever you have to
wrap your head around the fact that this
is still very much a fantasy
it's still very much a because it's not
this
so you've established three or four big
rocks that aren't what you had and she
happens to have those three or four
rocks and the challenges or the the the
fantasy part is there's three or four
other rocks that you that you had with
your ex that you don't even realize that
this new person doesn't have
so it's not a matter of I finally found
what I'm looking for as great YouTube
song says it's not that it is I'm
finally deciding that I can live with
these and I'm gonna I'm going to honor
these right it's it's it's not going to
be an even trade like you think it is
right now and that's the importance of
just slow playing it because you're
still
you're still so happy to be out of one
and oh my gosh she thinks I'm funny my
ex-wife didn't think I was funny at all
that was annoying right
um and then I think dude this is super
important
often often often often kids
when they are being introduced to Mom or
Dad's new boyfriend or girlfriend
they feel a sense of disloyalty to their
birth parents on the other side
as though if I accept dad's new
girlfriend
I'm betraying mom
and
if you and your ex were able to sit down
and be super transparent with one
another probably in a way that if you
hadn't been it would have saved your
marriage originally and say you're gonna
date again I'm gonna date again we have
to be in communication because your wife
may bring home some scumbag that you
don't want around your kids that's
number one and vice versa and number two
you need your your ex to say to your
kids when they come home and say dad's
got a girlfriend that her first words
are I'm so glad dad's happy
not tell me about her
because there's going to be this that
seed plant does that make sense
yes if that can't happen and it can't
happen in most divorces because again if
people were that much adults they could
have dealt with this way up Upstream
um you just have to be prepared for that
and then when it comes to like actually
joining up and you're talking about your
two kids suddenly being outnumbered in
their own house
so I would definitely if y'all decide
one day we're gonna we're gonna get
married we're gonna lock this thing up
that you would get
um some professional counseling to help
integrate here's what this new family's
gonna look like we get to create this
sucker kids mom dad everybody we're
gonna create what this thing looks like
one of the kids is gonna hate everything
about it and try to torpedo the whole
thing two of them are just going to go
along with it just because they are so
desperate for peace two are gonna check
out right so we're gonna
begin to spot each one of these kids and
how we can best love them because it's
going to be different for each one of
them but we're going to need a
professional for that and that's just a
part okay that's just a part of moving
forward I just wouldn't do it without
that
I totally agree so I'm telling you these
things tell me tell me what you're
thinking are you going okay cool that's
easy dude or oh geez like I need to
think this through
no um uh
I think it sounds like really great like
I didn't think about the professional
counseling part and I think it's going
to be huge
um and I know my oldest he he even told
me he can't wait until I have a
girlfriend so he can tease me for having
a girlfriend because I tease him for
having a girlfriend
and and do know this
children in in the situation like your
kids are in they will use very grown-up
words
they will nuzzle up to one or one or
both of you
this is a incredible excruciatingly
painful situation for kids
and so even when even when 11 year olds
making jokes like that that 11 year old
is um desperately trying to make sure
y'all's relationship is okay
does that make you see what I'm saying
yeah absolutely and so any any res any
um dysregulation from kids
I'm gonna give them a really gracious
pass for a while because their whole
world has exploded and they're going to
the mirror every day saying what did I
do what could I have done
what could I have done what could I have
done there's something that kids
experience um called the uh
reconciliation fantasy that is really
hard especially if you decide you're
getting a gauge or getting married
there's always this lingering sense in
the back of their mind that one day Mom
and Dad will get back together
and there's a there's another grief that
they experience after the initial
breakup when it becomes serious when
when Mom finally says hey I'm getting
married
then it becomes this oh this is forever
right kids don't have that that they
don't have that um
that sense of time yet
so all to say is this it's gonna be
really Rocky as smooth as you think it
is right now it's going to be Rocky and
that's okay it's just it's just keeping
space for it to be very uh complicated
and we did uh I did end up buying uh
there's two books that you recommended a
while ago
um about the two households and how you
know Mom and Dad still love you guys
that kind of stuff
um and I've read that to them several
times and both uh me and their mom are
constantly telling them that you know
this was a an adult decision this had
nothing to do with you guys
um we both love you guys very very much
um it's just honestly excuse me
something uh that we felt was right that
is gonna be better for them in the long
run as well I would give them an
opportunity to say words out of their
own mouth
sometimes when we get around our kids
we'll say things like this is on us we
did this and we explain stuff kids feel
stuff adults talk kids feel and so I
would whether that is once a week to
with your you know five-year-old to get
down literally lay down on your stomach
on your belly and y'all uh he or she
lays down and you'll make an eye contact
maybe you're coloring and say hey I want
to hear from your heart
tell me what you're sad about with with
us getting a divorce let them use their
words ask that 11 year old like what do
you what have you it's been a few months
tell me about what you're sad about
and let them just talk and they may say
nothing nothing and you can say I'm sad
it's not what I thought was going to be
going in I'm sad about it and then he
just know that sometimes I'm sad and
sometimes I'm going to do something
different and that those two things
aren't linked but you see what I'm
saying but let's give them an
opportunity to not just hear hear hear
hear explanations from adults but that
their feelings are important too and
they get to speak out loud because
they're going to tell you things are
going to stun you and they have a levels
of insight that often my my daughter
after the shooting here in Nashville
recently she's seven and she explained
some things to me that I was absolutely
floored that she knew and I do this for
a living right I was I was stunned that
she knew some of the things that she
knew so all I'd say is give them a space
to talk about it it's just gonna be
tough for them
okay cool
cool all right whenever you
um decide y'all are gonna um get married
and be all ew ew call in because I want
to talk to both of you I think that
would be make for a very fun phone call
that'd be fantastic thanks for calling
Sean I'm really grateful for you